oh
[Musique]
tiens salut mégane anna n'est pas avec
toi non elle ne va pas bien à les
malades non ben qu'est-ce qu'il est
alors ce sont ses parents par ses
parents sont malades non elle est
déprimée parce que ses parents ne
veulent pas qu'elle fasse des études de
médecine juste parce que c'est une fille
c'est fou ça pour plein de gens encore
c'est bon pour les hommes d'occuper des
postes à responsabilités comme médecin
chirurgien avocats ils ont moins
confiance quand c'est une femme mais
elle elle veut être médecin mais elle va
commencer par mail elle va faire comme
maria montessori barré à montceau quoi
ceux qui
n'auraient montessori c'est une femme
célèbre elle a fait des études de
médecine alors que son père était contre
elle a créé un programme pour que les
enfants handicapés puissent apprendre
comme les autres puis elle a adapté son
programme à tous les enfants dans ce
programme le professeur s'adapte à
l'élève aujourd'hui il existe plein
d'école qui appliquent ce programme
ouah je parcours donc tu vois si maria
montessori a pu aller contre l'avis de
son père hanna le peut aussi oui mais
mais quoi anna quoi la baisse n'est pas
marjah
moi je ne suis pas marié marvingt
et nous on n'est pas megan rapinoe
je ne suis pas emma watson
et moi je ne suis pas joséphine baker
toutes ces femmes se sont battus avec
courage ce n'est pas parce que nous ne
sommes pas célèbres que nos actes ne
compte pas les compagnies ne sont pas
finies et c'est à nous de les poursuivre
pour ne pas qu'on les oublie pour par
contre nous vous puis pour qu'on puisse
vivre la vie comble pour les que les
droits de l'homme soient aussi les
droits des femmes
[Musique]